[Music]
of all the people that have hurt me
the most it's kind of been been her how
has she hurt you casey she's
tried leaving twice
her whole life is i'm going to do things
the way i want them done and if i can't
get them that way i'm going to store
them off by myself
[Music]
read it to tell what's up this is john
with the dr john delony show hope you're
doing good hope you're doing well
hope you feel good
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at
four
1-844-693-3291
it's
three three two nine one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask and remember
we're taking your confessions
if you got stuff that you need to get
off your chest you never told anybody
things you did things that have been
done to you
give us a shout
go to johnolooney.com ask and just put
confession in the little box where you
type in and put it in there and of
course if you hurt kids or you've abused
people i'm gonna call the cops on you
um and i'm gonna try to put you in jail
other than that
we'll keep you anonymous right um
i'm just getting calls from all over the
planet about
um
people thinking they're the only ones
struggling with stuff that they've been
sitting on something for a long long
time i talk a lot about how secrets um
are the gasoline the jet fuel for shame
and you just can't live a life of the
secret secret secret secrets and so
um man we're gonna have a new segment on
the show just called confession so give
us a shout um go to johndelyn.com
ask all right let's go to casey
in boise what's up casey
hey dr john how are you man
well not too bad hanging in there
excellent what's up dude
so i uh i just got done reading your
your new book uh really enjoyed it
there's only like only like 10 people
bought that book man so thank you for
being one of them
oh that's all right i loved it thank you
man
the uh we're reading it though the the
section where you talk about kind of
having a box where you have a small
number of people you really confide in
you know you have a spiritual advisor
and a close friend yep you know one or
two and you also include your wife in
there and
i guess
my question is i i feel like i i can't
include my my wife in there and um
you know i really want to because she's
my spouse and i love her but i'm just
really struggling with how to how to
include her in that man so let me um
back out real quick and explain for
folks um if you're new to the show
this idea of a box on your counter if
you will comes from a conversation i had
in a counseling class and i was in a
back to during my let's get my phd in
counseling and we were in a classroom
and
we're talking about who hurts our
feelings and um
ultimately landed on i
people can can fire me and take away my
livelihood someone can shoot me and kill
me somebody can um break my leg right
but ultimately i am responsible i get to
choose who hurts me
and i realized in that class i give had
was giving access to everybody it's
people on the internets i didn't know um
politicians um friends of a friend
40 people that i was a a you know a
colleague with i was giving permission
for everybody and i was walking around
raged out hurt feelings sad
every time i come up for air somebody
else would say
i realize i was letting everybody in
side in my chest if you will to hurt my
feelings
and so the exercise was
limit it to five
and so i started saying okay who do i
let speak into my life
and good grief so i cut out all of the
parents of my students because they
would call in and they'd say something
like you
you failed my kid because and i would be
crushed by that i didn't mean to fail i
didn't want to fail your kid
finally i was like dj i'm not giving you
you don't get to hurt my feelings you
know you can say i'm i am crummy
professional camera my feelings
i was giving access to my in-laws to my
parents
they'd give me parenting advice and i'd
be like i'm the worst
i took him out and so ultimately in my
little box i ended up with the person um
one or two people who were
that i really valued their wisdom
they're older than me they were mentors
but they were spiritual they were people
that i trusted hey i'm about to make
this big life change what do you think
um
and then i had several close friends
that i've been ride or die with for a
long time i think i got mine down to six
i don't remember exactly what it was but
and then the first person was my wife
and i actually called them including my
wife and said hey i'm giving you access
to me
and um this is i'm a tough texas male i
know i'm not supposed to talk like this
but um you now have permission to hurt
me you have permission to speak into my
life so if you see me doing something
stupid call me out like you always do
um if you think i'm being dumb or the
clothes i'm wearing are ridiculous you
have permission to say something i'm
going to listen to you
and my wife was a key person to put in
there so that's that's the back story
there so then back to casey my obvious
question is man
why can't you
why can't you put her there why is that
so terrifying
well
you know i had a really stable childhood
growing up and very you know normal and
secure and loving and so i didn't have a
lot of you know as your book talks about
you know trauma childhood trauma or
anything like that
you know of all the people that have
hurt me
the most it's kind of been been her and
yikes um and so it's just really been a
struggle and how has she hurt you okay
um
you know
well she's tried leaving twice
um
she just uh puts the kids
you know
over over me ever since the you know
first kid was born
and
you know she's just uh
just not a priority that way
and when we try to have a deep
discussion or
really open up it usually turns
argumentative and
um
you know it's just just not a very
secure
place for that kind of thing
i'm sorry man
it's been pretty tough yeah
i mean i can't i'm just i can't wrap my
head around that man that hurts dude
um how long have you all been married
uh 17 years oh man
yeah and that the the trade leaving it's
been
twice within the last probably two years
okay
and i'm hearing that all over the
country has been a lot of chaos the last
few years and um so it's been a mess of
course have you ever gone to counseling
together
yeah we we did the first time when it
when it really came to a head about two
years ago
you know we went through counseling and
you know that was
very good and very encouraging and
you know
but the the counselor was
kind of pretty hard on on her
and because the whole time i'm thinking
am i doing everything right you know and
i write in my thought process
and the counselor kind of and it's a
counselor that she chose and
you know but yet the counselor was kind
of affirmed you know i'm trying to do
everything right my marriage and my
family and in life
you know she was the one that had a
bunch of things to work on and
and um
you know she didn't really respond
very well to that you know she said yeah
sound sounds good but then nothing
changed
is she seeing somebody else
no i don't think so okay
has she before in the marriage uh
no not that i'm aware of and i've never
seen any evidence of that
i'm just trying to
i'm not accusing her i'm just trying to
see all the variables here in a short
time frame but
yeah
here's he doesn't think very deeply
about things you know
yeah
i get that but that's different
um it sounds like she has no interest in
helping meet your needs
and that her whole life is
i'm going to do things the way i want
them done
and if i can't get them that way i'm
going to storm off by myself i'm going
to take my ball and go home
and
um
i mean we could have a whole woo
conversation about the wounded child and
all that but that's a very childish
response well then i'm just going to
leave then you know what i mean
um and so
here's where i'm torn man i'm torn in
two ways number one you do not put
people in that quote unquote in that in
that mythical box here that you don't
trust that you can't be vulnerable with
you can't open up to
and also
your marriage is really on life support
right now and i know you know that
um
it sounds like that's one of those
moments to sit down and have on those
conversations is like why
we are now adults choosing to live this
life and it's miserable why are we doing
this
can we decide to make this different
and the heartbreaking
answer to that question is
unfortunately
i don't want to do that with you
and so what i'll tell you is there's
this weird chicken or the egg thing that
happens
with that box if you will
where somebody hurts you
that you love
and forgiveness is hard
grief is hard like reconciliation saying
i'm sorry can be hard all those things
are hard
but then you pull that person out of
your box
they feel that gap
and it creates a
just a tiny shim
of space and that space just grows over
time
see what i'm saying
and so um
it just feels like one of those moments
and you've probably heard me say this on
the show where you just got to turn all
the lights on turn all the music off the
dance gotta stop for a minute we just
gotta say dude what are we doing
because right now we're adults and we're
choosing to live a less than life and i
don't underst that seems like a bizarre
choice to be making
you're choosing to not meet my needs i'm
still trying to meet yours
and i i can't imagine this doesn't
affect your sex life it doesn't affect
your work life it doesn't affect the
just going home and having a home be a
warm safe place to drop your shoulders
and go ah
but instead you get off work and you go
home and now it's like another job right
yeah it's uh you know and she doesn't
openly acknowledge that there's a
problem she looks around at our friends
and our family in the world and goes
well that marriage is it's fine there's
nothing wrong with it it's all good
i'm just like there's just deep no
things aren't i don't think they are
so if you came sat down tonight after
dinner and said hey um
i'd like to go back and see a counselor
again with the two of us
because things might be fine but fine's
not good enough for me i want things to
be incredible
and i'm willing to do some work are you
willing to do some work what would she
say
i i think you would say
that things are
fine the way they are and we've already
been down this road
and
or she would say you know i'm the bad
one you're the good one i should
be yourself up and say well i'm the one
that has all the problems and yeah
that's like that's just like nonsense
stuff into the marriage yeah yeah
that's just a that's just a throwaway
oh it's just all me huh you know what i
mean yes and then you back up and go no
it's me too i uh
you know i sometimes leave the
toothpaste cap out that's just like a
that's just a move you know what i mean
uh okay here's here's the hard and i
didn't see this call going in this
direction
um
what is your or what
what i mean by that is
i can hear it in you you're getting
closer and closer to an or what moment
what is your or what moment meaning
i need you to do this things around here
have to change or what
are you gonna leave
i
i i don't think my or what is is to
leave because i've
made a
you know biblical covenant with her in
marriage and i've talked to a lot of to
those other people in my box about it
and
the consensus kind of is it's like well
marriage is the
highest thing so you do whatever it
takes to
keep it together and keep it keep it
going but i always wonder at what cost
absolutely
and i really struggle with that and and
i want her to be in the box i want her
to be closer she's i do love her deeply
but it's just she's not true she's not
safe she's not trustworthy
right yeah so here's the here's what you
can do right now in this in this season
um
if i'm you i would go find somebo a
professional to talk to on your own
um in this variable that's the only
person you can you can
be about because you need some clarity
moving forward
i haven't expanded this is completely
john doloni here okay this is just a
personal thing i have an expanded view
of infidelity
of um i think as for for people who are
in biblical covenant marriages
um
this idea
of unfaithfulness
is much deeper than
did so and so hook up with somebody else
it's much much deeper than that
faithfulness and fidelity is i'm all in
physically i'm not going to sleep with
somebody else
emotionally
um spirit like i'm in
and when i'm part of
the reason why this unity isn't working
here
i am going to
from a point of fidelity and a point of
faithfulness to this agreement we made
i'm going to make some changes in my
life even when they're ugly and messy
and really really hard
and so faithfulness to me is a much
broader picture than somebody slept with
somebody else
okay now
that's not shared by
ministers and pastors all over the place
that's fine
what that means is there's millions and
millions and millions and millions of
couples who haven't stepped out on their
marriage haven't kissed anybody else
and
they say i mean faithful
yet they have
absolutely no
play they're not doing anything to help
love their partner better to help make
this union stronger to say i'm sorry and
do work on themselves that they need to
do so that the whole unit can be well
and by the way these kids are absorbing
this stuff
they're they're just absorbing it and
they're coming to understand well i
guess this is just what marriage is i
guess this is how mom's role i guess
this is just what dads do
and so this whole idea of faithfulness
and fidelity is a much much bigger thing
than who put what where
it is i'm all in and right now casey
dude
i didn't expect this call to get here
man
i don't blame you it's not safe to put
her in there right now and
the long-term viability of your marriage
is on really thin ice
and so what i'll tell you is at some
point something here changes
and when i know something's going to
change
i always want to be on the proactive
side when i if i have a retaining wall
at my in my at the back of my farm and i
see it starting to bend
i don't want to wait till it collapses
i'm going to call somebody out i'm going
to save the money up i'm gonna call
somebody out and have them come build it
and dig it out um otherwise i'm gonna
have a huge mess on my hands that wall's
getting getting dealt with one way or
the other i want to deal with it on this
far up the front end as i possibly can
sorry brother we'll be thinking about
you
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you that
you are important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to
jessica in missouri what's up jessica
hi um so my question is how do i deal
with basically being a single parent
when my husband works at night and on
top of that we just had a fire like
three weeks ago um i have a 15 month old
and a five month old
and i also work so how do i deal with
life basically your whole life is on
fire
yeah
wow okay so
hi jessica it's good to meet you hope
you hope you're doing well
um what's your favorite band
um i don't have one i listen to a lot of
music
so i don't have a favorite so you're a
serial killer that's good all right so
um ten and ten
months in five months wait what 15
months and five years one month and five
months they're 10 months and 25 days
apart
are they adopted are they biological
biological we had one in february last
year and one in december of last year
dude i'm high fiving you all the way
from nashville
wow okay
so yeah y'all are
there's y'all are crazy yeah no that's
not that it's not crazy it's i think
it's awesome but
y'all are in it but then there's like
y'all are in it in it okay so tell me
what happened to your house total loss
what happened ah so we had a mobile home
um
that we owned and we were like six
months away from being fully out of debt
and then saving to buy a house
and my five-month-old had thrush and my
husband was working at night so i was
you know dealing with both children and
had to boil the bottles and all that i
fell asleep while boiling the bottles
and our kitchen basically went up and
switched
oh no
so is it a total loss
um a lot of smoke damage not full total
loss but it's not worth replacing so now
we're fighting with insurance just to
get the money we're supposed to get so
that we can then buy a house yeah we've
been with his parents the past months so
it's it's a lot
have you already had the uh
fire inspector come out and write you a
letter that this is what happened
yep okay we have a fire report all that
okay it's just insurance came back real
real low like they always do and so now
we got a back and forth
all right so tell me about husband
husband is fantastic he's an amazing dad
he just an amazing human being he's like
my best friend
and we've been through it since we got
married and this is just another thing
but
it's just constant
and he
holds fuel
so he works friday saturday sunday
monday nights
and then he's also working on trying to
get out of a truck so he's also doing
electrical work to get his hours tuesday
wednesday and thursday gotcha um and he
has to stay up all night thursday so
that he can sleep friday so that he can
work all night friday night so he's
really only around
tuesday wednesday
maybe half a tuesday yeah
and by the way you know what you should
probably do right now just live with
your in-laws
that sounds like a good
man yeah okay
so here's the bad news
the bad news is
i want you to
like take as deep a breath as you
possibly can and just hold it will you
do that
hold it
three four then let it go
i don't want you to drop your shoulders
pull them down like as low as they'll go
okay
you have to own the grief of the season
you're in
like your house is gone
and you're gonna have some guilt
please don't roll it into shame you're
gonna have some guilt because you put
the bottles on the stove right you fell
asleep
and
guilt is i can't believe i fell asleep
and the house burned down
shame is i'm a terrible mother and i'm a
terrible wife and i'm a terrible family
partner because i burn the house down
you see the difference
yeah one is yes i feel guilty i did this
like all this mess i'm we're living here
because i did this
and that happens if you try to run from
that it will chase you down so you got
to own that and
i don't want that you to start looking
at that as an identity or a character
issue okay
here's the good news
everything you're describing to me is
seasonal
like i'm just looking at six months and
12 months down the road and how
different things are gonna be you're
gonna have your own home your husband's
going to be out of a truck working a
regular job
your kids are you're not going to be
just constantly rotating between feeding
and changing diapers 24 7 365 over and
over and over again
your life is going to look incredibly
different and so what we're talking
about here is how do we maintain during
the cold hard winter
does that sound fair
yeah
because it feels like your whole world
is on top of you doesn't it
yeah since we got married almost four
years ago because he did construction
for our entire dating relationship and
like two months after we got married he
got in the truck and was gone for two or
three months at a time for two years
and then when we got pregnant he found a
job that was
gone during the week and then home on
the weekend and then when we had our
first daughter then he was nighttime
so it was a lot of a lot a lot of things
have happened since we got married um
this is gonna sound like a crazy
question because you're surrounded by
people who love you but are you lonely
at times yeah
sounds like it'd be a lonely a lot
when my girls are awake they're
fantastic and they help yeah just draft
from that they are not
that's not what i mean
i mean do you have two or three or four
women in your life
that come over and talk trash and
makes fun of you while you're making fun
of them and
like do you have those women in your
life that bring casseroles over and
all that stuff
i would if i asked but i don't ask
okay
so the key to the next six to 12 months
here what your life is in transition
is
you make a firm commitment
to your kids
to your husband
and bottom line to you
that you're worth having friends
and make a priority i'm gonna have
people in my life
on a daily basis if not a weekly basis
and i'm gonna start having friends even
if they just come over and prop their
feet up and they do their homework
because they're going back to school or
they just come over and they all they do
is hold your babies so you can just go
close your eyes for a minute all they do
is come over and y'all watch some dumb
netflix show or whatever
um or it would be really great for you
um if they came over and you all went
for a walk and you got a double stroller
and you went and moved your body okay
got out of the house and went moved
um
but i want you to make having conhuman
connection a high high high priority
here's the second thing i want you to do
i said it a little bit you gotta get
into some sort of movement you gotta
move your body around okay will you
commit to that yeah you don't got to go
to crossfit class like a lunatic but you
do got to get a double stroller and go
for a walk a couple of times a day
at least once a day let me say that a
couple times would be great or if you
can go for a run or your friend can come
over and you can run to the gym whatever
and i'm not saying to go get bulk up i'm
saying just move your body okay
here's the third thing and um i'm
shooting in the dark here on this okay
um
have you gone back to your house
yeah actually this week we're
taking everything out and sifting
through everything so but have you gone
back yet
yep i was there yesterday how was it
it sucks every time i go tell me about
it
um it just makes me feel sad yeah
um if you can i would love for you to
get one of those girlfriends of yours or
just go by yourself
just go and be sad
okay
there's something um there's a beacon
that was home and it's not anymore
and you spent a lot of two years alone
in that place
pacing
that's where your babies were born and
they came home to
and now it's gone
okay
home
and i want you to go there and be real
real sad
is that cool
yeah it's best if you go with somebody
and this is gonna sound like if somebody
sees you doing what i'm about to tell
you to do they're going to think they're
probably going to call a psych ward on
you okay
i would love for you to take a friend
over and just kind of walk through the
house
and talk about where the memories were
this is the room that we brought
five month home to
and this is the room
this is where five month old was
conceived and this is right and we're
gonna laugh and we're gonna tell stories
and this is where i got mad and threw
food against the wall and this is where
husband came home and always dropped his
underwear and it was gro i want you to
go through and feel this place okay
yeah because it's home and right now
home has become a
epicenter of trauma for you it's been
it's become a nuclear reactor
and i want to change that in your body
to where it is a warm place that's got
some laughter and some joy in it and
some great sadness because we're not
gonna live there anymore and by the way
you're about to move anyway
right yeah we're working really hard to
move and so this wasn't your forever
place it just got expedited so
we're gonna go there we're gonna walk
through it we're gonna talk about it and
we're gonna make peace with it and we're
gonna kick our shoes to dust off our
shoes when we leave and then when you go
back it's gonna feel different you're
gonna feel lighter and then you go back
and you're gonna start moving and get
all your crap out of there get your
stuff out
and then you're going to leave that to
the burned out box that it is
but your home's going to go with you
does all that make sense
yeah sounds super woo-woo and cheesy if
you tell your husband over the road
trucker like all right this is what this
guy told me to do he's going to be like
you probably should never listen that
podcast ever again
okay oh no he listens to y'all in jail
he probably listens to dave and you way
too much honestly at night because then
he festers and just thinks and things
and thinks
and then tells me all the things in the
morning
so it sounds like you got a husband
that's working
absolutely working his butt off because
he loves his family and he wants to make
things different is that true yeah
100 and you got two
unbelievable beautiful little kids that
are just too much right now but they're
still beautiful
yeah and you got a couple of friends who
would at a moment's notice
come in and come be a part of your life
um but you just won't call
pretty much and you've got two in-laws
that are just their in-laws they just
what do you say but they also open up
their home to you right you see what i'm
saying
yeah here's what i'm getting at
you have to feel this grief you got to
own this grief because it's real and
don't miss the beauty don't miss the
light coming through the darkness
because there's a lot of light around
you that's what i'm hearing
okay
yeah
we keep saying that we've fought many a
battle since we got married and this is
the war and god's working all the little
miracles around it and it's really hard
to see all the little miracles when
you're in this [ __ ] of what we're going
through that's right so so here's what
i'm doing i want to change your language
okay
i want you to no longer you're not in
war anymore
what you've been doing for the last four
years is this the little farm y'all had
the soil was terrible
it's full of rocks and thorns and weeds
and nonsense and y'all been working for
four years
to change the soil
to clean that soil up to regenerate and
to heal that soil
and now y'all are planting
i'd much rather
a planting metaphor we're planting seeds
of trees that we might never even eat
the fruit off of them
but now we're planting because what that
tells me is at the end of a war there's
a bunch of dead bodies to pick up
at the end of a good planting season
is the harvest
and that is a radically different
psychological proposition for your body
and so let's tell your husband we're not
fighting war anymore i declare war over
war is over
we're planting
we're getting ready we're turning this
sucker around we in and he has worked
you have worked you spent countless
lonely nights
countless single parenting nights
countless at nights getting advice from
your mother oh gosh
kellen said nice just wishing your
husband wasn't such a great hard worker
and he would just come home and sit on
the couch all stinky mess of him and
just hug you
all that work y'all put in
the harvest gonna be big it's gonna be
big i'm super proud of you jessica
go make that call today okay go make
that call we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement mls id 1591
in the mls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's take one
more let's go to mexico city mexico and
talk to dan what's up dan
dan yeah you're john rather sorry man
yeah that's your name
what up
i'm all right i'm uh i'm doing well so
i've got kind of uh everybody really
liked that last call oh i've got uh
like an entree leadership tip uh
question for you okay hey talk directly
into your phone okay
okay how's that perfect much much better
perfect okay so all right uh you got you
got a leadership question for me
yes exactly okay so i'm an ex-minister
uh turned founder owner of a for-profit
company here central mexico um six
full-time employees i've come to see a
pattern
that i've got in collecting like um
skilled people that are also sometimes
kind of broken and complicated
and i tend to form these uh like really
cool
close mentoring relationships with at
least some of them
um and that's sometimes resulted in like
um i don't know cool kind of holy spirit
moments and and
really deep loyalty to the team from
these people commitment and stuff like
that
but they're not always or at least those
mentorship
activities and time expenditures are not
always advancing like the cause of the
company and certainly not the bottom
line always right i've heard dave
uh say that management is ministry and i
love that phrase but i'm not i don't
think i'm real clear about
excuse me
how to manage
some of that tension you know people and
then uh
and then you know getting stuff done
yeah absolutely um great great question
man and thank you i'm glad you have i
mean these anybody working for you is
gonna be fortunate right because you
have a heart of service and you don't
just want to crank out a bunch of uh
paper dollars and a bunch of widgets you
want people to be well right you know
people have good lives
have people have better lives because
they interacted with dan and i think
that's a that's incredible right that's
so good um so underneath all of this
i want you to keep this one idea
if the business goes away
you help nobody
you got that
yeah that's a fail that's a that's right
so we're not helping a customer we're
not helping our local community because
we're dumping tax dollars back into it
we're not helping with any of our
service or giving that our company does
and we're not helping our employees so
if the business goes away my mission to
help other people is over i got to do
something else okay
so
all of my
training and all of my
um enlightenment and growth
opportunities
in the work setting
have to be geared toward
helping this business to be successful
whatever that looks like that doesn't
always mean grow that doesn't always
mean sharing it just to whatever success
as you define it
if you do that and you give people a
purpose
the growth will happen
and you train people
the growth will happen
but we're not just training them
indiscriminately we're training them
towards getting well now um i the word
ministry i've get kind of a jarred
reaction to it
um yeah uh it's kind of like a yeah
right and
yeah i've always rolled back i i'm
always roll back to what the great um
rich mullen says
which is
be weary of anybody
that says they're doing a thing and then
they're doing their ministry
as though ministry is something you just
duct tape onto the side of something
that you want to be doing
and he goes on to say ministry is
flushing the toilet
it's tipping well it's taking care of
the custodian it's making sure you're
the last one to eat
that's what we have just we've
professionalized ministry and we think
it's all about
trying to get people to be spiritual in
the way that we think that they should
be spirit
ministry is service okay and so
um i'm gonna be about serving these
folks making sure their lives are good
or as dave has told me personally if
you're not good at home you're no good
here so leave my building and go home to
your family right he's told me that
before so
that looks great but all of that is in
service to
them growing as people so that this
business can survive so we can all eat
see what i'm saying it's both and not
one or the other what it sounds like and
can i challenge you on something
dude tell me i'm wrong
i know a lot of ex-ministers i've worked
with a lot of ex-ministers and current
ministers that wish they were
ex-ministers um
who have an addiction
to other people's problems
they find their value
their esteem
in making sure other people's problems
are solved
is that you okay
if it's not cool interesting
you know what
i will certainly chew on and reflect on
that but i am
tempted to say that i've got a
reasonably healthy
uh relationship to that thing like i'm
uh
yeah i'm i'm on the same page it was a
big revelation to me to like leave the
you know professional christian job
title and actually be serving
you know as under the lord uh and
through for-profit that you know in that
uh
capitalist world out here i love
business i've since i found dave ramsey
and and i and i love fixing problems in
the marketplace um
but i uh
yeah i don't know about i don't know
about addiction i will reflect that's
great sometimes
i don't i don't want to put uh i don't
want to put thoughts in your head that
aren't there right um i just want to
make sure you're not hiring people that
may have a little bit of a bent
listen
uppers and yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of
part of the question yeah and so um you
wrote um my i tend to have employees i
tend to find employees that are broken
and complicated what i would tell you is
that's all of us
that's all of us yeah every employee
you're going to have is going to be
fighting wars that that you as a boss
don't know about all of them yeah
whether they're past wars that keep
showing up or their future wars that
haven't happened yet or their current
wars every employee and that's the
messiness of working with people um i
have had
to
have a radical conversion of my soul
since i worked started working here
because i worked in non-profits for 20
years i was i worked in education
settings in colleges universities and in
school in um you know k-12 situations
and i didn't even mean to
i thought i was doing the good stuff and
business was just keeping the lights on
for the for the world
and since joining this squad
i have been astounded at how wrong i was
and just like i've been around really
toxic non-profit folks in my life
um who are 100
in the business to make money and to
skirt taxes and to lift their own lives
up
and you've been around those people too
the opposite
i work for a company whose sole mission
i would say pathologically so
is serving a customer
because behind closed doors here it's
give well then give it away then just
give it to him then just give it to him
right
then we're going to spend extra money to
make sure this person's life is a little
bit better
and so every conversation here
relentlessly is
well what about the what about the
person on the other end of this call
what about the person on the other end
of this book
and so i have had to i've had my whole
insides have changed
now i don't judge either one of these
things i look at the people in the
organization and say who are you about
serving
right so
i'll tell you it's taken me a minute to
get there it was so jarring and maybe
you're just starting to have to
reconcile some of the thoughts you had
as a minister and
be okay with making a profit making
money and it's okay in fact it's right
it's noble it's good it's how do you
make sure
and how you honor people is is that are
you feeling at peace with your new role
a thousand percent like dave the dave
ramsey you know pro-business
pro-christian ethical capitalism thing
was a bombshell for me and i'm i'm all
in and very excited about i have more
kind of like holy spirit goosebump
moments
in a you know a month maybe
than i did in five years as a minister
and
i'm just in my calling and i'm in my
channel um but i yeah but you know and i
agree i'm not the business is not like
at the brink of
you know uh catastrophe because we're
sitting around in prayer meetings all
day when we should be
getting stuff done
but i feel like there's maybe a moment
of like a decision between
like excellence in the marketplace
versus mediocrity and in some
kind of more touchy-feely
uh
types of things that don't
always directly connect to you know the
tactical
progress yes um i love that so what i
would tell you is
in the details maybe i don't know just
kind of feeling out
that tension i guess the tension will
always exist okay
the marketplace is a beast that can
never be filled that can never be fed
it'll never be satisfied
there has to come a moment when you say
enough
our company is as big as we want it to
be
um
we have enough revenue we don't just
need to continually mindlessly
scour the earth for a quote-unquote more
or we're going to find a different
different person with the different
challenges to go serve and help right
we're going to give them create a widget
for them we're going to create a program
for them or whatever whatever your
business we're going to make sure their
lawn is done right so that they have
more time to go back with their families
right so whatever that thing is that
we're doing i'm going to make sure the
toilets are super super super clean
so that nobody gets sick so that they
can walk in their house and drop a
shoulder right so whatever your service
is
um that you're getting paid for
let's do excellence across the board
and let's go back and look at the things
that we're doing in the office
the why behind what we're doing with how
we're honoring our people and i think
honoring is good i think having time for
reading and reflection spiritual growth
those things are good because they
ultimately lead to a great a stronger
healthier well-rounded human
that also
it can then show up and be really good
at work
and that person can be really good at
home and then that person can go to
sleep at night and repeat though right
you see what i'm saying so it all works
together and if our business is well
then we all have food and lights and
transportation and what right so it all
works together it's the segmenting out
that makes it a mess so go back with a
with an eye for intentionality
and start looking at here are the things
that we do
here's the conversations that we have
here are the act quote-unquote
activities that we do
how is that leading to
the end person
that we are serving in the marketplace
how does that make the person that that
i that works for me how am i serving
them
and let's be hyper intentional about
that linear fashion does that make sense
yeah for sure i mean that's like a
that's a framework
it's gonna be a yeah learning curve to
kind of figure out what that looks like
on a on a day-to-day thing but that's
that makes sense there's also time um
also time to do things out of the office
what i have found as a leader um one of
the la i think i may have talked about
this on the show one of the last um
performance evals i had at the
university was um i got one negative
thing on it and it was
deloney you have to stop running into
burning buildings
we have people that do that your job is
to
be at the command central and make sure
everything's running yeah right
that was a frame that was a shift for me
and my my boss who's a great man he
called it out and he said hey
that's not your job anymore
and dude i miss the burning buildings i
know that sounds crazy i miss the
adrenaline i miss going to help people
right in the middle of the moment but my
job became helping the people that are
helping the people and so i had to shift
and the discipline to say no
to
opportunities where you could help
because they
are not
i don't know uh so that's that's a
sometimes thing like you know i'm not
going to go
uh
show up in that
opportunity to serve or help because
it's out of my scope or it's out of yes
and subtract from this bigger cause and
that's a hard that's a hard thing and
then maybe
honestly there's maybe some like uh
what you're talking about before like
um
underlying ego of like it feels good to
show up and have a right answer or a
game changing the best thing yeah it's
the best i'm just trustful of how good
that feels oh dude i love it i love it
but what i had to learn as a leader is
yes i could solve your problem
my job right now is to refer you to a
professional and then get you the help
and care that you need and i don't have
to be that person for every single
person in fact i can't be and if i try
to be
then i am using time and energy on
something that somebody else can do
probably better than me closer to
that is going to take away from
something else
and so what i'm looking at across the
country right now
and i'll go i'm going to be speaking to
3 000 business leaders in a few days
they are drowning in their cl and their
in their
employees mental health challenges
and they love their employees
just like you do right just like my
company does yeah loves the people
and we're gonna take care of you but the
way we're gonna take care of you is by
scaffolding and resource um resources
we cannot be everybody's therapist if
you run an electrician shop you are un
it's unethical you're not qualified to
be their marriage therapist or their
counselor or their grief counselor
whatever
what you can do is say hey dude you're
welcome to leave an hour early this week
get out of here go to see your counselor
everybody if y'all need to go see
somebody feel free to knock off an hour
i'll even pay you for it go see somebody
and then get your butt back here and get
back to work
right or hey your mom just passed away
you let me know when you can come back
go go be with your family we'll figure
it out next week
right that's the way you can honor
somebody and you've got a list of five
counselors in your building to call or
two
whatever's and you tell people hey guys
i can't come to every graduation every
birthday and every crisis i just i can't
make all of that
i want you all to tell me who you have
in your life
that you ca that will go with you and
teach them how to cultivate those
relationships in their lives
so you're teaching them how to fish
right
yeah and that's generational changing
because then they're going to learn how
to have friends and close relationships
and they're going to learn how to look
in the in a book and call up for a
therapist and go show up for that
appointment
and their kids are going to watch that
happen and now you're talking about
legacy change and generational change
and you're gonna watch people who were
trapped in addiction cycles and um
for you this is a ministry this is
bigger right you want them to meet are
you a
christian so yeah yeah you want them to
meet jesus then and
yeah you're going to model what that
looks like so that they
learn how to go about and do that
see what i'm saying
it's just it's just shifting your role
as a minister your job is to show up to
everything
as a leader your job is to show up and
teach people how to
see what i'm saying
yeah if i'm if i can if i'm paraphrasing
back to you kind of to take away like a
practical step like one of those
thoughts that's big for me outsourcing
help
rather than always being the help
for team members making space for it or
provisions but not always kind of being
the
whatever the the helper the fixer right
and maybe the other one that maybe seems
a little bit more challenging or
um
difficult for me is the um
saying
no there you go two perfectly good
places where i could show up and make a
difference because it's
because it's outside the scope and you
know i guess i need to get a framework
for we're super small there's you know
there's only there's there's only nine
of us total and so
you know we know each other well and uh
and i'm very accessible and i don't know
what point that
what what kinds of boundaries start
coming up as as
as scale you know when it's time to say
that's outside of my scope and i need to
let someone else
do that or i need to just or maybe there
is no one else who's going to do that
but i can't i can't take my off the
surprise right now to go show up for
that and some of that is i sat down with
my team
three universities ago because i was on
call 24 7 365 so i got every single call
and i couldn't do it anymore
and i had 13 i think 15 direct i
remember how many was it was a chunk
and
finally i said
if someone's going to the hospital
somebody's suicidal
call me
everything else i trust you guys to deal
with
yeah and dude you know what i got for
the first time ever
sleep and i got to spend
uninterrupted time for a season with my
family
and that allowed me to show up even more
full and better the next day
so that i could love the people that
were working for me
i could honor the end customer there
and i could start that whole cycle over
again
and so play a long game here with your
team
not death by bb i'm going to show up at
every single thing every single thing
no i'm going to create a
entire ecosystem of support and care
that sometimes includes me but usually
doesn't
and it's going to include referrals and
other people and you guys stepping up
and you're calling each other and you're
getting your own friends
and y'all getting your own church or
whatever that looks like for your
company
i'm going to create an ecosystem
much much different it's a it's actually
much harder than just showing up and
doing it yourself
but that's what leadership is and dude
dan i'm proud of you man those guys
working for you are lucky lucky lucky to
have you as their as their as their team
leader that's incredible thank you so
much for the call we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show the song is from the one
and only
you two
and the song is 40 and it goes like this
i waited patiently for the lord he
inclined and heard my cry he brought me
out of the up out of the pit out of the
miry clay i will sing a new song
how long to sing this new song
you sit my feet upon a rock and made me
f made my footsteps firm many will see
many will see and hear and i will sing a
new song
but how long to sing this song
[Music]
i don't know
i guess you'll have to come back and
listen again we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode when i'm
in a vehicle with somebody else
especially as a passenger my anxiety is
through the roof oh there's nothing
nothing that husbands like more and
their wife is like you know what you
should be doing
that's exactly me i tell him what to do
turn here look here look out for that
card
jerry don't do that i am 31 but i have
cerebral palsy i walk independently with
no assistant devices or anything like
that
but i just struggle in this one area
when it comes to dating because i just
don't feel like i'm the one someone's
going to choose